[Música]
alrededor de medicinas que son las
adicción
[Música]
y lo digo así porque en la nación
pareciera como primera reflexión que
tendemos a olvidar la ex esquina
no nos pasa con otros temas de la
ciencia de la salud voy a dar un ejemplo
distinto no es el tema de oro si
sostuviera para hablar sobre intención
[Música]
nosotros
nadie olvida la esencia
todos saben que jagger y tuberculosis lo
mismo
todo se resida en él
bueno
y podría venir a darle a los chicos una
charla sobre las ingles
la cual cuando se sentaba
sin embargo todos prácticamente dicen
doctor no podía darnos una charla sobre
las adicciones como si fuésemos
y tendríamos que decir pueden estar
sentados tres años para escuchar todo
sobre todas las adicciones
cuando hablamos de infecciones
no decimos
igual nunca escuché a alguien decir
sabes
y así
héctor mismo no escucharán decir
tuberculosis es peor
o es mejor
asociar carta de las inspecciones es
informante y todas son importantes cuál
es la peor la que padece la persona
si un hijo
ni siquiera apareció otro no son mis
afectos
por eso esto nos escucha decir este
horno con tuberculosis o hepatitis
[Música]
para voluntarios nuestros cálculos es
que somos una suma de los órganos o
somos una persona de la política
integral
por eso esto de las elecciones nos habla
sino las misiones
no tiene ni idea la cantidad de veces es
mucho decir drogas
y lo mismo
como siempre dijeran chagas y sidra
me da lo mismo tomar un vaso de vino e
inyectarse una jeringa de heroína
obviamente nuestro mismo mirador mi peor
escuchar a una persona es decir el
trabajo
es peor que la marihuana
qué va
parecerlo
para el metabolismo de los lípidos para
la función de las células naturales
china para la memoria inmunológica para
la síntesis de interleuquina 6 yo no
entiendo qué es lo que estás diciendo
alfredo nosotros tenemos que entender se
mantienen investigamos y trabajamos en
el tema
pero como va a ser lo mismo un año 2000
en mi peor todas son informante la peor
es la que padece la persona que amamos
por eso tengamos en cuenta que cuando
queremos conocer un perro de las ffaa
cuestiones uno por uno a mí si te dice
alfredo porque estamos otra para de
programarlos con mucho gusto alfredo
podría darnos sobre cabras son la
enfermedades ya que por ejemplo con
mucho es una charla de inmunología de la
tuberculosis
alfredo no puedes dar una charla de
tuberculosis a qué rapidez y da
parásitos intestinales ni solitaria y en
la vid o si junta no porque después
terminamos confundiendo
o bien dando una charla sobre alcohol
poder dar una charla indicando
absolutamente diferente sobre el
tabaquismo sigue podéis dar una u otra
tanda sobre también de diferentes
explicando sobre ludopatía adicción al
juego si podéis dar una otra tabla
absolutamente diferente
explicando sobre estupefacientes sigue
preparando todo
porque se extiende a la primera
reflexión
diferente
los estudios que le pediría hasta con el
tema de las infecciones creo que nos
sirve como lazo para colgarnos en la
perfección los estudios y le pedirías el
laboratorio de ovario grafía en
cualquier método de diagnóstico por
imágenes adaptación de que tiene
los pulmones son los mismos que los
pacientes que tienen y no los estudios
el alcoholismo sólo lo mismo que viene
tabaquismo
[Música]
el tratamiento que le darías a un
paciente que tiene una convicción italia
con la tenía satinada es el mismo
parque tiene una sartén un protozoario
con el celular o alguien tiene el barrio
y no no el tratamiento que le darías a
un paciente que tiene el tabaquismo
es un receta bautismo es el mismo que le
daría a quien sufre una adicción porque
hay
por eso estemos tranquilos
en recordar raíz la paralítica
[Música]
para diagnosticar para investigar para
tratar la relación cada una
la segunda reflexión sobre la pasión es
la primera
una vez
sólo son diferentes todos son
importantes todas merecen mentes
así es que sin mi vida
hay muchas fantasías alrededor del
nombre de la palabra lección incluso
seis personas que dicen adicto quiere
decir sin pagar nada
[Música]
objeto rosado puedo tocar al panellinios
a un objeto objetivo por ejemplo no
puedo tocar si lo puedo medir por
ejemplo la ambición política
a los que los presos una vez se dijo voy
a ver de qué se trata
van a interactuar en un sexto intermedio
la corteza cerebral
y sólo tenemos los canteranos superiores
los cristianos después de bebiendo
gratos
los autos inferiores peces anfibios y
reptiles
ese palo termina un poco
al cual no ha regulado en este sector es
el cerebro intermedio hay altos que dos
cosas u objeto objetivo que si se supo
de ellos no van a actuar el empecé por
fraccionar de mi cerebro sino que van a
actuar en este sector
el motivo instintivo nacional del
cerebro y van a caminar
se trata pero a partir de allí voy a
llegar a abrir mirada nueva a costa de
extender me de ese objeto y agregado ha
venido y cada vez que ve más
con más frecuencia con más dosis y le
costará más dejarlo porque habré caído
en la pela de araña de un mecanismo
pasional
veinte metros que comisión a dicha de
tres mil euros al mes y sin recibir
porque el objeto me dejó a mí pero sí
quiero decir sin palabras es decir
visiones
no es a ti
y dictó en latino es palabra estudio de
bendición millonaria pero hasta para
decir que significa la paja
adicto significa que hay una población
de unas vulnerabilidad física técnicas
biológicas farmacológicas
al atacar
y teclados
hasta que la cuerda liberarse de él y
hacen cosas
y la primera vez cómo funciona con algo
que no funciona nada hacen la revisita
tercera reelección
[Música]
él
empieza con una clave
las adicciones son las cosas
[Música]
baja
y alguna vez
de vuestro hotel me gusta siempre
transitar por otros para jugar a la
reflexión cuando ustedes quieren tener
una enfermedad de sida
no recuerdo ninguno
y quiere tener una neumonía severa aguda
por coronavirus un síndrome agudo
respiratorio severo producido por el
corona minutos y para entrar ya en tu
mano
[Música]
y quiere tener en casa
fíjense que en todas las ciencias algo
no queríamos a ninguna
ahora es la pregunta
acaba de lanzar a una reunión terminando
de tomar un café y alguien te dice el
otro
quieres oxidarse interesa un publicano
y su cabeza me dice
y alguien que ve que su dependencia
o más
que puede tener una
saleh
[Música]
con una pregunta
tienes
y siguen con una respuesta como contigo
sí no
pero a partir de ahí
ciao quiero tanto sino que luego como si
fuese el caso del otro sin querer
queriendo sin querer queriendo cada vez
queremos más y más y más y más frecuente
y luego decimos esto me atrapó lo tengo
que dejar y los hermanos
tinsa
y medallas
y dijo
y legales
verdad porque el mercado de algo que se
llama síndrome de stevens
y entonces puedo a buscarte porque sufre
sin este objeto pero vuelvo a dañar y el
12 digo que tengo que dejar tu cuerpo
una enfermedad crónica que evoluciona
enfermedad crónica que oposición a
conocer caídas basadas en al arrancar
con una pregunta que en ninguna otra
enfermedad o patología o situación no
hubiéramos dicho lo poderes
y sabiendo los daños hubiéramos dicho
sin embargo por los juegos de las
adicciones
arrancan como unas cosas
ah
las acciones pueden ser
a sus ganancias
o puede ser así
por ejemplo la adicción que más ha
subido en los últimos años está
cuando tienes que crear una revisión
puede que de verdad
tres tipos de edades diferentes primero
si es una sustancia química que daña mi
puerta con facilidad
no hace falta que estaba
[Música]
el corazón produce el cerebro
la canción
[Música]
estoy bien
tengo en contra patillas sufren de
atención al cuerpo
hoy hoy a las maquinitas hoy al casino
viendo toda la herencia de mis hijos el
esfuerzo de toda una vida lo que ellos
les permitía estudiar ir a la
universidad y lo perdieron una sola
[Música]
como sufre esa familia que a veces que
tocan el timbre y se asoman por una
rendija para ver si son las personas que
vienen a llevarse algo por un embargo de
la vega el televisor la cocina los
productos de la casa porque la persona
que tenía la patología de encima y
entonces vienen a cobrar le deja
a veces cuando
un grupo de profesionales atienden a
pacientes que sufren de adicción al
juego de ludopatía más que poner una
camilla para realizarlo etcétera
y se traga las pastillas las fichas en
el casino y si llega alguna en el
hipódromo pero hay que poner tantas
sillas sin ninguna camilla
[Música]
la decisión de engañar a la familia
si ha dicho genera la dependencia por la
cual para comprar el producto al
proveedor necesito dinero y en la casa
ya no hay que robar y mi trabajo ya lo
abandoné por eso la corte escribiendo de
dónde sacó el dinero para comprarme
cocaína
probando revirtiendo para poder
conseguir el dinero porque soy en
esencia un delincuente
estoy limpiando para poder satisfacer
esa demanda que ha ocurrido en mi
cerebro el corazón instintiva emotiva no
racional y entonces se daña la sociedad
por el exceso del alcohol
poder y si manejo pobre sociedad algo
sin estar en condiciones de hacer
a veces y por eso hay que pensar sólo en
el año qué órgano hay que ver que
dañamos sin querer a quienes más
queremos que empezamos diciendo si
quiero y terminamos dañando sin querer
sobre todo a los que queremos recordar
entonces quedamos sin querer no sólo
[Música]
queremos
porque más
ah
las adicciones con sustancias químicas
muchas veces surgen de una fantasía
preguntamos a personas o por qué toman
la palabra
para pasarla con eso
al gobierno vamos a pasar no no
y por qué consumir esta sustancia
porque consumir té está superando
[Música]
el objetivo en la abrirán esta mañana
dañando la familia dañando a la sociedad
visto necesitarlo
por eso sin entrar en cada una porque
era una apertura de reflexiones
las cantinas rurales puedan compensar
una por una podemos pensar en que la
persona lo hizo diciendo tiene lo que
debió haber dicho no quiero pero luego
sin querer dañando si quieren a quienes
más quiere lástima todo lo que haga
dañando la sociedad no somos un cuerpo
y luego pensar en esto la fantasía de
pasar bomba nadie la pasa bomba
si eres el camino de cenar y de gusto
saboreó una copa de vino si fuesen el
hombre tengo siglos de generación grasa
de vino
tengo un intolerancia del alcohol o su
propia mente a la corte físico
pero mi casa porque no te puedo degustar
la copa de vida
alguna vez a quien sé cuál es
a ver
a contar la misma estupidez siempre es
el mismo grupo
hay que darle abrazado al mismo de la
mitad
a la resaca del día siguiente
[Música]
el manu
y cuando descubra qué
con el auto de propiedad y víctor meza
penalmente
qué bomba valió la pena crear de la
bomba
para vivir así todos los años que tiene
estar fondeado y bombardeados
no yo
sino sugerencias y reflexiones los
ánimos
[Música]
no miramos
de forma de elegir
no es bueno estar con el cerebro
abordado no es bueno estar descontrolado
luego habrán ascendido a la adherencia
de toda una familia en una noche de
juego de una noche de casino
[Música]
pasa la bomba con el buenísimo recurrir
a la capacidad de correr a los que
quieres
solamente el cielo
y la última reflexión que quisiéramos
hacer en este caso
si nuestro objetivo es pasar bomba el
método puesto
todo es todas las sustancias son manos
no nadie sabe si son malas o son cuidan
las sustancias no son mala ni buena
las hay de tóxicas y no tóxicas las
intoxicados y tóxicas grandes dosis pero
la sustancia
es el error de recurrir a ella con un
pensamiento mágico con esto yo soy otro
puedo volar por las alturas por los años
no a un conocido que no para estar en
abu sin acciones puede usar una
sustancia de origen entero para ver si
diálogo con dios y dentro del mundo de
la espiritualidad pudo recurrir a unas
sustancias por ejemplo cuesta más horas
despierto y que eso es bueno venciendo
el equilibrio del sueño y de la vigilia
o puedo creer que con esa sustancia
voy a pasar por una siesta terminando
con un accidente
un acto de violencia posterior hagamos
fantasías
la pasemos por mi sueño nuestro sueño
compartido sería que frente a esto
cuando alguien nos diga que eres
nosotros una respuesta me queda dentro
sin pensar si si quiero mi vida mi
proceso mi futuro a los que hagan mi
sonrisa mi felicidad quiero pasarla toda
mi vida bomba
no quiero quedarme un segundo bien